charlie morton having a really good year
25 starts 12-4 3.47
era 164 strikeouts in 140 innings well
you are right michael another good
season the atlanta braves signed him for
one year 15 million dollar deal and he
has been great hasn't missed a start his
fourth in the national league and wins
with 12.
and believe me we have seen him before
this is his 14th start including the
postseason against the yankees since
2017 only blake snell has more with 15.
two quick strikes for le mayhew and a
little chopper dansby charges
third hop got it and a strike for out
number one
so lemay hue is hitless so far in the
series here is anthony rizzo
as strike three rizzo's retired on three
pitches two up two down his first
curveball of the night and he froze
rizzo two down here in the top of a
scoreless first inning that brings aaron
judge to the plate here's the payoff
pitch to judge
fastball is lined to right center field
there's a base hit for judge
so that's the 17th game in a row he's
been on base judge lines the fastball to
right center hoping to make this next
one his final pitch in the first pitch
on the way swung on and lifted out
towards left field adam duvall coming in
he's there he's got it and that's out
number three well charlie morton gives
up one base hit that's it the top of the
first inning no runs one hit no errors
one left former angel current yankee and
a man that has watched the ball fly away
an awful lot this year yeah look he's
coming off his best start of the year
against boston seven innings pitch to
it's one earned run but he said he's
going to sit low 90s with his fastball
with a curveball and change but 16 home
runs given up in his last 53 and a third
oh one pitch on the way ground ball
guided out to short backhanded by
velazquez he was very busy last night
and busy to start tonight's ball game he
throws down ozzy all bees in one down
and speaking of solaire he swings at the
first pitch another easy ground ball
he's
got two quick outs in the blink of an
eye he's got two outs on three pitches
and now freddie freeman's up so full
count here it comes for freddy and he
takes high ball four there's your first
brave space runner freddie freeman 71st
walk of the year freddie came in second
in walks behind juan soto that was a
close miss so all this trouble with two
outs a walk and a hit batsman brings up
red hot dansby swanson
swaying and a shot headed for the gap
that's gonna get down and score at least
one right second little stumble they're
gonna wave him here he comes around
third relay throw to the plate is gonna
be late
dance me on an o2 count puts atlanta in
front two to nothing yeah just a hanger
he said he see him choke up choked up
almost a whole inch there got a hanger
and gapped it doing what he's been doing
now for close to last month hitting 440
with runners in scoring position three
rookies for stanton last night a home
run and the two-run double
that one is ripped deep to left field
duvall turns looks sia a home run into
the first row in left center stanton
continues his hot hitting and it is 2-1
braves that was an absolute missile
another breaking ball a line drive
though i mean it just carries aaron
boone calls him the unicorn because you
see things from stanton that you never
see from another player now here is he
needs one two to morton
and he struck him off swing so what do
you think
andrew heaney just struck out the side
no balls two strikes and charlie morton
has struck out the last four yankee
hitters good start back to the top we go
le mayhew grounded out softly to short
his first time up
and morton came back to get him he is
humming that's five straight strikeouts
and eight combines in a row now look at
that location 96 bottom part of the zone
sinking it's not easy to strike out dj
lemayo he's a contact hitter there's
aaron judge who lined a single to right
center his first time
that one's fair inside first and it's
going to go down the right field line
playing him in the corner is solaire and
stopping at second with a lead off
double is aaron judge so he's two for
two well here judge line the line every
once around here you kind of emergency
hack and it just seems to stay fair all
the way to the wall big at bat here for
sanchez sanchez struck out to start that
impressive run of five straight punch
outs for charlie
morton grounded through the hole against
the ship it's a rbi single and a tie
game smart hitting there by sanchez he
picks up the ribby picks up judge and
it's a 2-2 game so two on two out now
peterson struck out swinging his first
time up was that a foul ball was he hit
by the pitch and they're saying he's one
around so he strikes out
and peterson does not like it it was
bill walkey at third base who made the
call so even if you're hit by a pitch if
you swing the bat the swing supersedes
the hit by pitch so peterson is out he
does not like the call i don't know if
it was the length of the argument or if
he said something objectionable to the
empire but he eventually got tossed one
on one out lemay here the leadoff man
breaking ball is swung on hit in the air
to left field and deep that ball is high
hit us far that is gone
into the yankee bullpen in left field it
is a two-run home run for la mayu
david john makes long gone he hits a
two-run blast to left and the yankees
take a 4-2 lead braves have some work to
do they're down four to two now alby's
at third freeman is that first two men
out
ground ball through for base hit
that'll score albies
freeman is rounding third he's coming
home the throw is
in time they get him the tag by sanchez
for the final out of the inning so a big
hit for riley to make it 4-3 but then
they try to score freeman from first the
brazil looking at it and he's out so
that would be six two
little pop hit toward le mayhew if he
can avoid the umpire he did it and makes
the spinning catch
and handcuffed everybody chad whitson
was trying to get out of the way lemay
hugh almost ran into him
and swanson's retired for out number one
it's all fun now
once you catch the ball but when you're
trying to get out of the way and you
don't know who's bumping you if you're
dj lemay you like not like you can call
pass interference yo that's definitely a
flag
leads off braves have a shift on for him
that one's drilled deep to right there
it goes
see ya
oh what a blast by odor and the yankees
lead five to three you shut the door or
door the yankees just keep coming at you
keep tacking on runs all of a sudden
looking back at the braves 5-3 instead
of 4-3 on one swing fastball right there
and the o2 on the way
that is punched out to center sprinting
in radia slides to it and a terrific
play
makes the catch sliding right across the
painted 44 out there in the outfield
grass catch like that make your heart
skip a beat that seemed to lead off in
what a great play
grounded up the middle of base hit off
the bat of riley
freeman's going for third
[Applause]
and the throw to second they get riley
trying to advance
not a smart play by riley as freeman
push the action going to third
but they get the out at second 02 coming
to swanson
and the pitch is grounded to third roogy
to field and throw across in time and
that will win the unit yankees have used
six pitchers tonight with a day off
tomorrow they're asking chapman to get
the three outs here in the ninth three
two
strike three got him looking at a slider
two away
two outs bottom of the ninth the braves
have duvall at second adrianza at first
and ozzy at the plate
ground ball hit to the left side
odor scoops and fires and as he beat it
in field head albies beats it out to
keep the game alive yankees trying to
keep their winning streak alive at 10 in
a row looking for 11. ball four it's a
one-run game
has seen enough of chapman obviously
very disgusted and now he turns it over
to wandi peralta so these are moments
that mvps are made of and the pitch
fly ball
left center on the run is gallow he's
there to make the play and the yankees
hold on take a deep breath everybody the
winning streak is 11 straight
[Applause]